pour sylvie c'est l'heure de la
cueillette quotidienne depuis début
octobre elle arpente chaque matin ces
deux mille mètres carrés de culture afin
de récolter à la main ces précieuses
fleurs violettes elles serviront à faire
le safran faut qu'elle soit bien quand
même sorti de terre qui est un minimum
de queue après si elle est pas si elle
n'est pas ouverte c'est pas grave elle
s'ouvre elle s'ouvre elle s'ouvre plus
tard avec la chaleur ce couple d'anciens
céréaliers cultive transforment et
vendent en direct son propre safran
depuis dix ans la plante réputée pour sa
robustesse et capable de résister à des
températures inférieures à - 10 degrés
et à des températures caniculaires on la
trouve dans des pays chauds on la trouve
aussi en montagne par exemple quand même
en france dans les alpes de haute
provence et on en trouve en plein comme
chez nous ce qui est très important
c'est le sol un sol drainant filtrant le
bulbe du safran qui produit le safran de
ce caucus ne supporte pas d'être noyées
dans l'eau après la cueillette c'est le
moment de l'émondage chacun de ces
pistes il rouge et retiré manuellement
du reste de la fleur avant d'être stocké
vendus ou transformés 180 à 200 fleurs
sont nécessaires pour produire un gramme
de safran soit on le vend donc en
filaments aux restaurateurs en vente
directe aux clients soient effectivement
non on transforme d'en dégeler chutney
sablé au sirop l'objectif de la vente en
direct pour le couple d'agriculteurs
ouvrir le safran à un public plus large
de consommateurs et débarrassé cette
épice de son image de produits de luxe
le safran et est accessible ça coûte
quelques centimes par assiette seulement
et ça peut sublimer une quantité de
plats aussi bien salées que sucrées qui
est infinie c'est dommage de passer à
côté de cette épice
sous prétexte que c'est une épice trop
cher en fait c'est trop cher si on
achète le flacon qu'on met dans son
placard et qui ont de l'oubli là c'est
sûr que c'est trop cher malgré les
efforts des cultivateurs pour
démocratiser le safran la culture de les
pistes restent encore très
confidentielle en france
dans le cher ils sont moins d'une
dizaine à le cultiver